[Music]
[Applause]
I think it'll be two weeks tomorrow that
Kalen dor took over Alabama for Nick
Sabin coach of course LED Washington to
the national title game now the new head
coach at Alabama well you've been there
almost two weeks so uh coach how's your
accent has it
changed no it hasn't still got that uh
still got that Midwest uh kind of feel
to it I think and it probably always
will so but it's great to be on your
show Dan I appreciate having me on where
are you right
now we're uh in Alabama just uh making
our rounds and on the recruiting Trail
so it's uh going great uh when you said
two weeks uh kind of hit me about how
fast time's been flying by so we're
making the most of every minute the
coaching staff's coming together nice
and um you know just really proud of how
far we we've come in a short amount of
time all right the number one thing that
you had to do as soon as you hit ground
in Tuscaloosa was
what well you want you you know meeting
with the team and uh really trying to
get in front of them and um just uh you
know the craziness of College athletics
and in particular the portal and um just
trying to make sure that they they got a
feel for who I was uh you know in the
moment soon as I landed got in front of
them but uh the next you know four days
or so uh trying to meet with them
individually in groups you're trying to
build a staff at the same time and
showing them the vision and uh feeling
the personalities of those that will be
coming into the program to coach them so
that uh balance right there um you know
kept kept me busy uh for those you know
four or five days and uh now it's it's
kind of reaching out and getting to the
recruiting um you know that's been done
whether it's guys that have signed and
just trying to continue to impress on
them uh their importance in our program
and I'm excited to have them joining us
and of course uh the classes in the
future the 25s the 26s and so forth well
also were you recruiting re-recruiting
some of your players who were going to
go in the portal or at least talking
about going into the
portal yes uh absolutely you know and
that's that's a that's a big part of it
I think that's probably some of the best
recruiting our coaches have done so far
is is really recruiting our own roster
and uh you know that's uh it's crazy to
say that but um you know I think that's
the case no matter what but I think it's
even even at another level now uh just
with everything so I'm really proud of
the way uh our guys uh when I say our
guys our team have uh been receptive and
embraced our coaching staff and myself
um I think we've done a great job of uh
retaining um the core the nucleus of of
who's in in this program there's so many
great players and they want this place
to be great and uh you know
certainly um caught them by surprise and
uh you know it hits you pretty hard when
uh you know coach Sabin retired and um
that's a big piece of why they came here
but they also came here to wear wear
those Alabama colors and um you know
they've really again been receptive to
to myself and um holding it together and
wanting to carry on the legacy of this
great place do you get coach sabin's
office yeah I do I do it's uh it's I
think about all the people that have
been in there in the wa wait he cleaned
it out so did he leave anything for you
in his
office I haven't found it found it yet
there's probably a few things that uh
you know he he'll we'll talk about and
uh you know articles and uh things like
that but uh yeah yeah he's uh he's he's
going to be certainly around the campus
and uh you know excited to have him
around uh so much institutional
knowledge and just everything that I can
draw on um I've said it many times I'll
say it again be pretty foolish not to
use him as a great resource I know he
wants this program to continue to be
great in the future okay did you have
that moment where you sat there in his
chair at his desk in his office by
yourself and just said to yourself I'm
the head coach at
Alabama yeah it's a it's certainly a
special place and uh coach Sabin made it
that way you know and U you know I think
that piece uh of it was intriguing and
and exciting to me when going through
this process of looking to being the
head coach uh and you know he's made it
an amazing job as have others that come
before him too and so um yeah the the
Legacy leaves uh you can't help but
notice it and um you know carrying on
that tradition uh that's uh that's my
goal when did you hear or your people he
from Michigan prior to you taking this
job did Michigan ever reach out to you
about the possibility of replacing
Jim
Harbaugh no no this was this was all
about Alabama here and this is prior to
you taking that that I know Michigan had
a wish list there of in case Jim was
actually going to go back to the NFL so
i' I and your name was on that from what
I was told so I was curious if they ever
reached out to you prior to you taking
Alabama yeah no that would never have
been uh anything that have been made
aware of I think you know when you think
about the timeline of quickly things
happened from a national championship
game and you know two days later coach
Sabin uh retiring and the next day uh an
interview and then hired them there just
wasn't a lot of time for anything so uh
you know um it's been a whirlwind and
excited to be the head coach to Alabama
what did you do with your Washington
gear I don't know yet I haven't been
back since I took the job so it's it's
probably sitting there in the closet
some somewhere uh but uh you know we
we'll get back there and you know get
the family moved down here and uh is
that strange though isn't that strange
coach that you just you get up you got
to go you got to hit the ground running
and your family's still back
there yeah it was uh it happens fast and
that's probably the the unfortunate
thing of all this is how quickly it
happens uh I probably spent literally
five to 10 minutes packing a bag and wow
forgot a lot of things and just enough
to to get through a few days and
actually that carries on for a few weeks
but you know you just there's no great
way to be able to you know talk to the
fan base and your your team um you know
I'll get to that here as things settle
down and make sure uh everyone truly
understands how much I appreciate them
um you know when you're the head coach
you invest a lot of time into it as well
as well as people investing in you and
uh I you know certainly that place has
uh got a special place in my heart and
always will but you know those players
there are so special and again happens
fast it's the unfortunate part of just
uh the business and how things go yeah I
know it's it's really the crappy side of
all of this that you know you you get
that team to a national title game those
kids and all of a sudden you know do you
even did did you get to say goodbye to
anybody I got a chance to be in front of
the team and even not all of those guys
just with how quickly it happens uh you
know we're able to get the message and
be there and that's again a very unfor
it um you know not the way you want to
have it have it happen but within you
know 10 minutes you're you're sending
out a message to the team after I've uh
accepted the job and um you know I was
on campus and and met with the staff
briefly um and told them how much I
appreciate them and and met with the
team and and literally had to you know
fly down here and get to work um and
meet the team and and all the things
that we talked about earlier about you
know recruiting the roster and thinking
about uh you know getting this
organization uh rolling as quick as we
can well good luck on the recruiting
Trail thanks for joining us coach yeah
my pleasure thanks for always having me
on Dan appreciate you kayin dor he's the
Alabama head coach hey you take the job
next thing you know it's like uh hey can
I get together with you get on a private
plane and you're gone hit the ground
running